especially on this spacecraft probably
the only time I'll be on this base graph
to be honest yes the guardians of galaxy
spacecraft yeah what everybody's been
saying like where are we what is this I
don't really know what I'm talking about
because I have not read a script I've
never met even half of the people in
this cast yet I've only I've done the
majority of my screen time with my
friend Anthony Mackie couldn't be here
because he had to have one of those
Cuban cigars but that's okay cuz the
Winter Soldier is always kind of
figuring out you know what where he's
you know what environment he's in so bad
guy what do we know I think I think
that's always it's the question you know
and in a good way to be honest because
the thing is that I actually haven't
really thought about it other than the
fact that like every time you see him
he's in a very different place and he's
not really like a very like dangerous
guy for the most part but I feel like
you know he still got the hair and
walking and as long as he has this
situation going then I think he can look
a little skeptical got an edge yeah
buzzie at the same time okay talk to me
about the relationship and the chemistry
really between the Winter Soldier and
the Falcon to me it's like Martin
breasts film classic Midnight Run you
know it really is just sort of like in
my head like 48 hours or or a buddy
comedy from the eighties you know or the
nineties that's that's how I see it you
know we got to spit off Falcon we
absolutely can yeah absolutely
okay you know I mean the right people to
make that happen are certainly within
feet from us right now that's true
that's true what about the relationship
with Captain America Steve Rogers and
the Winter Soldier where does that all
stand right now I think that's in a good
spot I think that's a good spot
obviously you're all regulating no okay
it's it's tough you know because it's
interesting actually because in life in
the similar way friendships develop and
they change and sometimes you can know
someone for you know 15 20 years but
people change and sometimes they go in
different paths and those two guys have
certainly known each other for a long
time and they have a lot still in common
and a bond but now they've each had a
lot of separate life experiences so
while they do remain close it's
interesting to think about that they've
actually become different people than
how they started out so how that affects
their relationship is always going to be
this is as good as it gets this is we
are the last hope for Humanity you want
to get deep the world is ending the
world is ending in this film and you
know a couple of people I've gotten
together and they're trying to to save
it hey everybody so I be getting a lot
of requests to do more infinity war
previews for the characters so this is
all about Winter Soldier obviously in
his arc through to phase four I do think
that he has a good chance of becoming
the new Captain America of Chris Evans
leaves I'll explain on some of the
things he said during this interview it
sounds like their character arcs are
pushing in that direction should they
choose to go down that route like laying
track for a lot of these smaller
characters to become bigger characters
if the movies during phase four require
that or have room for it so if you're
finding me for the first time be sure to
subscribe to get all the Marvel videos
there's gonna be crazy amounts of
infinity war and Deadpool dropping
really soon there's a new round of that
Infinity Gauntlet giveaway going on all
you have to do to enter just be a
subscriber leave a comment on the video
so the really big stuff first let's just
like go down the list of things that he
reveals in this one he hasn't spent
really any time on the Milano
or the new guardianship they're calling
it the new guardianship and making it
sound like they're the ones that
actually bring this Q ship to Planet
Earth but the articles that I was
reading about that weren't super clear
like it's always a problem when you can
tell the journalists aren't big comic
book fans so they just got a report
stuff without any context like wait a
minute are you trying to tell me this
isn't an assist ship this belongs to the
Guardians so when he says that like 90%
of the scenes that he's had so far have
been with Falcon exclusively
it sounds like he only enters the film
in a big way when teamcap brings vision
to Wakanda and that's when Falcon comes
to Wakanda so then he starts having
scenes with Winter Soldier like witty
jokes about midnight run buddy road trip
comedy he's talking about a lot of the
scenes that they had during civil war so
there's a lot of that continuing through
infinity war just like the two of them
together with a little bit of comedy
amidst all this crazy stuff that's going
on can you see them no guys look I'd
love to keep this up but I've only got
one job here today and I got to impress
mr. stark so I'm really sorry the really
funny thing though is that when he jokes
about oh yeah you know there are
actually people standing off screen here
the green light that Falcon Winter
Soldier spin-off movie you wait deep
enough into phase four you could just
call that Captain America four if Chris
Evans either decides to leave or he
never takes the mantle of Captain
America back the icing on that cake too
is when he starts talking about the
Captain America Winter Soldier
relationship during the movie he's that
you know they've been through so much
together but they're completely
different people at this point so he's
referring to the fact the Captain
America is so jaded with the idea of
America that he's taken the mantle down
like he's blacked out the star on his
chest he's basically the nomad character
from the comics someone whose character
and identity was defined by their
country and then went to war with that
when he says that Bucky is a completely
different character he's basically
saying that he's not the Winter Soldier
anymore he's not a tool of some foreign
government I've already done a video
talking about how surety deprogrammed
his mind basically just took all the
Hydra stuff out of his brain remember
how the Black Panther movie kind of
teased the concept of him becoming the
next Captain America with his clothing
I'll link that video that I did for that
at the end of this Sebastian Stan
actually specifically addresses the idea
of becoming the next Captain America so
you see the strings that Kevin Feige is
pulling in the background they freed up
the mantle of Captain America and they
put Winter Soldier on an ark that allows
him to become that character should they
choose to do that down the road
he also jokes about Robert Downey jr.
during the interview saying that I don't
think that we've seen him on set yet
making it sound like they don't spend a
lot of time on
together which makes sense given the
trailer scenes we've seen so far most of
the Ironman that we've seen so far is
either at the sanctum or at the battle
on Titan against Thanos but I think the
idea is is that everybody comes to
Wakanda by the very end of the film but
because that's supposed to be like the
entire third act of the film it's not
like everybody shows up right away at
the beginning of this attack so I think
the ideas is that they start out rolling
into battle with just these characters
that you see on screen here but by the
very end of the film like before they
hit their climax any of the Avengers
that survived that battle on Titan come
back to help out but again I'll
reiterate I think that if anybody is
going to be leaving or dying during
these films of the two characters
Captain America and Winter Soldier
Captain America is the more likely
candidate so let me know in the comments
what do you think is going to happen
with Captain America and Winter Soldier
during the next two Avengers films and
who is your pick for the next Captain
America like do you agree that Winter
Soldier is the best candidate
it's just that of all the people that
could potentially become the next
Captain America like pretty much him and
Falcon he has the much more compelling
arc taking the mantle to honor his
potential fallen friend to buy hot dogs
you blew three bucks trying to win that
stuffed bear for a redhead what was her
name again Dolores
you called her top she's gotta be
hundred years old right now so are we
pal
what'll happen is is because I wasn't
expecting this to drop as I'll name the
new giveaway winner when I post new
Marvel which should be in the next day
or two leave all your requests in the
comments below click here for that video
where he talks about becoming the next
Captain America and click here for the
video where the directors confirm
Captain Marvel for infinity war thank
you so much for watching everybody stay
awesome I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]